مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى حصاد هذه
الليله الذي نخصصه
لتغطيتنا المستمره للاحداث في السودان
ونبدا بالعناوين
في مقابله مع الجزيره البرهان يقول انه لا
يرى شريكا لاجراء مفاوضات معه في الوقت
الحالي ويعتبر انه لا خيار الا الحسم
العسكري اذا لم تعد قوات الدعم السريع الى
مواقع ديسمبر الماضي وحميتي يقول للجزيره
ان الهدف من عمليه العسكريه هو التخلص من
البرهان وبدا عمليه تحول ديمقراطي
وقبل ساعات من استقبالهم عيد الفطر
السودانيون على وقع ترقب ومعارك دون حسم
قوى سياسيه سودانيه
تتقدم بمبادره القوى الوطنيه تتحدث عن
قبول طرفي الصراع بوقت القتال خلال العيد
وخلال اليوم اشتباكات في الخرطوم بمحيط
القصر الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه
ومواجهات في ام درمان وفي مدينه الاوبيض
والفاشر بولايه شمال دارفور
بعد اجتماع اممي افريقي اوروبي يناشد
اطراف الصراع في السودان وقفه اطلاق النار
لثلاثه ايام خلال فتره العيد
يقول انه يدرس خيارات يقول انه قد يلجا
اليها لاجبار طرفي الصراع في السودان على
وقف
العنفاجون يستعد لارسال تعزيزات الى
المنطقه تحسبا لاحتمال اخلاء السفاره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم
وفي التداعيات الانسانيه للمواجهات توقف
العمل في اكثر من 70% من مستشفيات الخرطوم
والمناطق المتضرره من القتال منظمه الصحه
العالميه تصف الوضع الصحي بالكارسي الامم
المتحده تقول ان ما بين عشره الاف وعشرين
الف شخص فروا من السودان الى تشاد
اذا يوم سادس من المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان ورسائل من البرهان وحميتي ودعوات
من الامم المتحده الى وقف اطلاق النار وسط
تحذيرات من وضع صحي كارثي وقوى سياسيه
سودانيه تتحدث عن قبول طرفي الصراع بوقف
القتال خلال العيد هكذا هو المشهد في
السودان عشيه اول ايام عيد الفطر وقبل
استطلاع ابعاد تصريحات البرهان وحميتي
نقترب اكثر من صوره الوضع حاليا من خلال
مشاهدات مراسلينا
معنا من وسط الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم
قوات هيثم دعنا نبدا بالمعطى الاجدد
مبادره القوى الوطنيه ماذا نعرف عن هذه
المبادره وماذا عن ما حكي عن قبول طرفي
الصراع بهدنه خلال العيد
نعم مبادره القوى الوطنيه والتي هي تضم
شخصيات من قاده حركات الكفاح المسلح
الموقع على اتفاق جبهه وقاده احزاب سياسيه
وبعض الشخصيات العامه قالت بانها اجرت
اتصالات مع
قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان الدقلو
وانهما حصل على موافقه مبدئيه من الطرفين
على هدنه خلال فتره العيد هذه هي الهدنه
لها بعض الاشتراطات تعمل هذه المبادره
الان على دراسه حلحله هذه
الشروط لوضعها في مبادره شامله تقول بانها
تعمل على تطويرها لتكون
يعني وقفا شاملا للنار بين طرفين وتكون
مدخلا لمعالجه
الازمه والخلافات عبر الحوار ليكون هناك
حل نهائي ودائم لهذه المشكله هذه المبادره
التي يترقب كل السودانيون ان تكون هناك
هدنه من اي جهه كانت ايضا تاتي في
بالتزامن مع المبادره او الدعوات التي
قالها
الامين العام للامم المتحده عند اتصاله
بطرفي الازمه وعندما اتصل برئيس مجلس
السياده كذلك حسب اعلام مجلس السياده بان
قائد الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده تلقى
اتصالات من رؤساء كل من جنوب السودان
ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي وايضا رئيس التركي
رجب طيور الدوجان الى جانب وزراء خارجيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقطر
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكذلك مدير
المخابرات المصري كل هذه الاتصالات كانت
تصب في بامر واحد هو الاوضاع او التي
تشهدها السودان وكيفيه ايجاد وسيله لوقف
اطلاق النار دائم خاصه خلال فتره عيد
الفطر المبارك هذه المناشدات الدوليه كلها
تنصب في هذا الاتجاه ومن الواضح ان
التكثيف الحراك الدولي حول هذا الامر
والضغط ايضا الداخلي الوضع الانساني
المتردي والوضع الصحي وكل هذه عوامل يعني
تضغط في اتجاه لابد ان تكون هناك مبادره
او يكون هناك وقف او هدنه في اطلاق النار
ريثما تتم معالجه الاوضاع الداخليه هل وضع
توقيت معين لهذه الهدنه كي تدخل حيز
التنفيذ اذا كان الطرفان موافقان عليها
بحسب المبادره القوميه ان هذه الهدنه ربما
خلال ساعات سيتم الاعلان عنها لانهم الان
يعملون على الاشتراطات او
الملاحظات التي ابداها كل من الطرفين حول
هذه الهدنه المرتقبه هناك بعض التفاصيل
يجري الان دراستها وربما خلال فتره وجيزه
يتم الاعلان عنها قبل بدايه يعني العيد او
المرحله المقبله من
فتره العيد قبل دخوله اي ربما تعلن هذه
المبادره وكيفيه الاليات التي يمكن ان
تراقب لنا واحده من الاشكالات التي كانت
يعني حاضره في الهدن السابقه التي لم تصمت
بسبب الخروقات المتكرره انه لم تكن هناك
اليه محدده لمراقبه ومتابعه هذه الهدنه
وبالتالي ربما الان يتم دراسه هذه
الاليات وربما في الساعات القادمه القليله
ربما يستمع السودانيين الى خبر ينتظرونه
جميعا بان تكون هناك هدنه واني على الاقل
ربما ينعمون بعيد وان كان يعني ناقص
الفرحه ولكن على الاقل ان يكون ان تصمد
فيه الاصوات الرصاص وان لا تكون فيه احزان
ولا يسقط فيه مزيد من الضحايا ولا مزيد من
الجرحى وهذا ما يتمناه الشارع السوداني
ان يتبلور هذا الامر بشكل اكبر ماذا عن
الاوضاع الميدانيه حاليا وخلال الساعات
الماضيه لا سيما في بقع البقع التي يتركز
فيها القتال في القياده العامه والقصر
الجمهوري وايضا الوضع في المطار
في هذه اللحظات يسود هدوء حذر هنا في
منطقه وسط الخرطوم وايضا القرب القصر
الرئاسي ومحيط القياده ولكن اذا ما عدنا
ساعتين للوراء كانت هناك اشتباكات ما تزال
مستمره كانت نسمع ايضا بعض اصوات
الانفجارات لربما يعني اسلحه ثقيله او
اشتباكات ثقيله بالاسلحه الثقيله كانت
طوال اليوم هذه الاشتباكات مستمره خاصه في
محيط القياده العامه وقرب المطار وايضا في
محيط القصر الرئاسي لم تتوقف هذه
الاشتباكات الا في هذا المساء في هذه
الساعات هذه هي الاشتباكات طبعا يعني حرمت
الكثير من المواطنين الذين كانوا يتمنون
ان يستفيدوا من هذه الهدنه ليغادروا
المناطق التي يحتجزون فيها بسبب هذا
النزاع وان يلتحقوا بذويهم في يعني
بفتره عطله العيد وايضا ربما المستشفيات
التي تجاور هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه ايضا
هناك مرضى لم يستطيعوا مغادره تلك الاماكن
شكرا لك هيثم مراسلنا من وسط الخرطوم
ننتقل الان الى منطقه السجان غربي الخرطوم
من هناك ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره محمد
الطيب محمد ماذا عن الاوضاع لديك
محمد هل تسمعني طيب للاسف يبدو اننا فقدنا
الاتصال بمراسلنا محمد الطيب في منطقه
السجانه في غرب الخرطوم قد نعود اليه
لاحقا في سياق حصاد هذه الليله في حديث مع
الجزيره اتهم رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان قياده الدعم السريع
بالتسبب في الاقتتال في السودان من اجل
الطموح الى حكم السودان وابدى البرهان
استعداد القوات المسلحه للتفاوض اذا
انسحبت قوات الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم
والتزمت بمواقعها ما قبل ديسمبر الماضي
اذا تراجع الطواف الدعم السرير وعادت الى
مواقعها واخلص العاصمه نستطيع ان نجلس
معها من تبقى منهم لكي نتفاوض لكن في هذه
الظروف انا لا اظن ان هنالك خيار اخر غير
الحكم العسكري
عدد كما كانت في ابريل او في ديسمبر عند
توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي ديسمبر العام
الماضي حتما سيكون هنالك وضع مختلف
نعود الى مراسلنا محمد الطيب الذي ينضم
الينا من منطقه السجانه في الخرطوم محمد
ماذا عن الاوضاع حيث انت
محمد هل تسمعني محمد الطيب
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال للمره
الثانيه هناك مشكله كما يعني بات معلوما
في الشبكه شبكه الاتصالات مع السودان لكن
رغم ذلك نظل نواصل رغم حديثه عن التفاوض
استبعد البرهان اي حوار مع حماتي وقيادات
الدعم السريع اضاف كذلك ان الحسم في موقع
حماتي كنائبا له في مجلس السياده ما زال
مؤجلا
نحن نحافظ على الاطار المؤسسين ونحاول
ونسعى في
تخرج بلدنا باي صيغه من السياق الى بر
الامان ليس لدينا قيود ليس لدينا حدود لكن
لدينا ثوابت وطنيه لدينا امور لا يمكن ان
نترايا عنها يجب ان يكون هنالك جيش وطني
واحد وهو رب الموضوع سبب قيام الدعم
السريع بمهاجمه القوات المسلحه اننا نتحدث
عن ضروره توحيد هذا العسكريه كانت دعم
السريعه تستبق التوقيع على الاتفاق سوء
النهائي للام السياسي الذي يقصد هذا
الهجوم القادم الذي اعتبره غادرا وخيار
وتمرد على الدوله لاننا كنا نثق في وجودهم
كانوا متواجدون معنا في كل مكان في مرافق
الخدمه العسكريه
وبشان العمليات الميدانيه اكد البرهان ان
المعارك الابرز تدور حول المطار في
الخرطوم وان الجيش يسيطر على باقي
الولايات مشددا على رفض توسع القتال الى
مناطق سكنيه
قواعد العسكريه كلها في قبضه القوات
المسلحه
المطارات في الولايات وفي الاقاليم كلها
القوات المسلحه
سوى هنا في الخرطوم موجود صحيح في بعض
المواقع الحيويه التي لا نزعة
من خلال القتال نحن لا نريد القتال ولا
نريد الحرب نحن لا نريد ان نزيد من دوامه
العنف لا نريد ان نقات وسط الاحياء سكنيه
لا نريد ان نقسم هجماتنا مصطلح
[موسيقى]
الدعم السريع
لا ضيران يتمركز في مواقعهم ويكون القطار
خارج المناطق السكنيه وخارج المدن التي
يتضرر بسبب السكان
في الجانب الاخر قال قائد قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان محمد حمدان حميدتي في
مقابلته مع الجزيره ان الهدف من العمليات
العسكريه في السودان هو التخلص من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والبدء في عمليه
التحول الديمقراطي
الانسانيه بنتكلم
لفتره معينه
قراني
الدبلوماسيه مثلا
علوم
ان قوات الدعم السريع تلقت اتصالات من كل
الاطراف بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي لتعزيز الهدنه لكنه حمل
الجيش مسؤوليه فشلها
الشديد انا
حميتي اضافا للجزيره انه يدعو الى تحول
الديمقراطيا حقيقي والبرهان هو السبب
المشاكل التي تحول دون تحقيقه
بالمناسبه اختبار يا اخوان الاوروبيين
والغربيين بصفه عامه الديمقراطيه لو داري
الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
اختبار بالنسبه
هو سبب المشاكل
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين قائد القوات البحريه السوداني
السابق الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين كيف
وجدت التصريحات التي وردت على لسان
الطرفين اليوم في هذه المقابلات الخاصه مع
الجزيره
المشاهدين وكل عام وانتم بخير
ونسال الله الرحمه والمغفره للشهداء
والتعاجل الشفاء للجرحى وانا اقول يعني
التصريحات حقيقه غير مبشره بخير يعني
كل يتحدث من من مكان يؤكد في انه يعني غير
راضي في ان يصل بالامر الى نهايه تفاضيه
يعني
البرهان يقول انها لن نتفاوض الا ان يرجع
الدعم السريع للمواقع التي كانوا فيها
يعني انهم يعلم الاستسلام ويكون انتهت
التمرد بتاعه انتهى وكده
بالتاكيد يعني حماتي ايضا من حديثه لا
يقبل بذلك ولن يقبل الا بان يزيل البرهان
من المشهد وهذا يعني بالتاكيد يؤكد ان هذا
القتال سيستمر ولا في هدنه حتى
تفاوضات لكن حديث البرهان عن ان هناك
امكانيه للتفاوض في حال تراجعت هذه القوات
الى مواقعها في ديسمبر الماضي الا يفتح
امكانيه من اجل فعليا التفاوض
اذا كان
الحميديه جبل ان ترجع القوات الى مواقعها
قبل الخامس من ديسمبر هذا يعني هو استسلام
هذا يعني انه استسلموا وغبيوا بان تمردهم
والان استسلموا اللغات المسلحه بعد ذلك
سيكون التفاوض على دمج الدعم السريع واصلا
القوات المسلحه منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
اعلنت انها ليس لديها مشكله مع افراد
الدعم السريع كل افراد الدعم السريعه حتى
الذين حملوا السلاح وقاتل القوات المسلحه
صدر عفوي عنهم اذا جميعهم في رواه المسلحه
وجميعهم يمكن ان يتم المسلحه دون
ايدنا وشرط
ما يتعلق بوابه الدمج المتفق عليها اصلا
في القوات المسلحه بخلاف ذلك يعني اذا اذا
قبلوا وخرجوا الى اراضي ما قبل خمسه
ديسمبر اذا سنمضي الى التفاوض حول الدم
ويبقى اللي شروط الدمج اذا ضمنيا يعني
انهم استسلموا
هذا
ورد
وهذا طبعا الا يبدو لك ذلك ممكنا الا يبدو
لك ذلك ممكنا
الا يبدو لك ذلك ممكنا عوده هذه القوات
الى القوات الدعم السريع الى مواقعها قبل
ديسمبر بالنظر الى ان البرهان تحدث في
المقابله عن ان الجيش متقدم في المعارك
صحيح وانا اقول لو قبلوا بهذا الحل اليوم
افضل من غدا لانه كل ما يتدخل وكلما تزيد
الخسائر في وسط قواتهم جزيره خسائر في
المدنيين ليستمر هذا النزاع بهذا الشكل
المدمر ويعني الخاسر هو اشاره السوداني
لكن اذا غبلوا اليوم يعني يخرجوا الى
اراضي التي كانوا فيها قبل خمسه ديسمبر من
العام الماضي نعتقد انهم حضن الدماء ويمكن
ذلك ان نصل الى معالجه لهذه الازمه بطريقه
يعني توحد القوات المسلحه السودانيه وتجعل
منها جيشا وطنيا واحدا شكرا جزيلا لك
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين قائد القوات
البحريه السوداني السابق ضيفنا من الخرطوم
ومعنى من الخرطوم الان الباشا محمد الباشا
تطبيق الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي سيد
محمد الباشا الطبيق
باعتقادك ما مدى امكانيه تلبيه قوات الدعم
السريع
لقول البرهان انه مستعد للتفاوض اذا
تراجعت الى مواقعها في ديسمبر التي كانت
فيها في ديسمبر الماضي هل هذه القوات
مستعده للعوده الى تلك المواقع
[موسيقى]
الكريمه والتحيه
للبيت السوداني وكل عام وانتم بخير واسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يفقن دماء المسلمين
في السودان وان تعود بلادنا ان شاء الله
الى الحكمه والى السلام والامن ان شاء
الله
اي اي يعني مطالب تعزيزيه انا افتكر انها
غير غير منطقيه يعني لانه الان نحن في في
واقع الان هو يفرض نفسه تماما يعني لانه
الكره الان في الميدان وكل الان في
المعركه واي فرض له تقديراته وله حساباته
العملياتيه
يعني ما حكم من مصر او مع مع من
في اي مطالب تعجيزيه قد تكون مقبوله من
قوات الدعم السريع انه الان المعارك هي
مهتدمه وانا اكون في الميدان والكل يعني
حساباته
على هذا المطلب هو مطلب تعجيزي
الان الان يعني
كل الاطراف وصلت الى مرحله قد تكون اي طرف
حسب حساباتي هو المنتظر
ففي هذه الحاله يعني يرى الطرف الاخر ان
هذا الطلب هو الطلب تعجيزي
والمنطقه الوسطى التي ممكن يرتدي تلتقي
فيها كل الاطراف هي الحوار شروط الان لانه
الان يعني لحقل الدماغ وللمعانة التي
يعانيها الشعب الانساني بتعليق قاسيه
وحفاظا على مصلحه السودان ويحدث السودان
وعدم
انحدار الى الى الحرب الاهليه انا اعتقد
انه لا بد من القبول يعني الحوار والتفاوض
من غير اي شرط العام يعني ولكن لم يتحدث
السيد محمد حمدان حماتي بهذه اللغه انما
قال انه التخلص من البرهان كيف تصف هذا
المطلب اذا كنت تعتبر مطلب الجيش بعوده
قوات الدعم السريع الى مواقعها في ديسمبر
الماضي هو مطلبا تعجيزيا ماذا عن هذا
المطلب بالتخلص من البرهان
والله ما قالوا سيدي الكريم محمد حمدان
تقييمه التي هو يعني فيها الان وتقييم
العملياتي وموقفي على الارض وسيطرته على
الارض هذا هذا حسب تقديره هو لكن انا في
تقديري كل هذه الشروط الان الوطن والسودان
فوق كل اي فوق اي اعتبار لانه الان نحن في
ظروف حريه جدا وقد تؤدي الى تفقه السودان
وقد تؤدي الى حرب اهليه شامله لذلك لابد
على كل الاطراف ضبط نفسه والرجوع الى صوت
العرض تحديم صوت العقل والرجوع الى
التفاوض من غير شروط من اجل وحده السودان
من اجل استقلال السودان لانه الان ما يحصل
ان افتكر انه هو دمار للبنيه التحتيه
للسودان وهو تمام لسودان وقد ينزلق
السودان في حرب الى حرب اهليه لا تنطي ولا
اعتذر
حينها لا ينفع لا ينفع الندم وفي هذه
الحاله يتطلب تدخل الدول
الرباعيه والثلاثيه والدول الاساطير
السودان
على الطرفين قبول يعني
للقبول
للوصول الى الى طرق يعني مسلى لمعالجه
المقطع الراهن يعني شكرا جزيلا لك الباشا
محمد الباشا تطبيق الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي ضيفنا من الخرطوم
في هذه الاثناء اعلن مكتب الناطق الرسمي
باسم الجيش السوداني ان الرئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان اصدر قرارا
الغى بموجبه قرارا سابقا بشان ضم قوات حرس
الحدود لقوات الدعم السريع ووضع قوات حرس
الحدود تحت امره الجيش اوضح مكتب الناطق
الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني ان تنفيذ
القرار سيبدا اعتبارا من اليوم الخميس
تنضم الينا من نيروبي السفيره
مبعوثه الاتحاد الاوروبي للقرن الافريقي
سيده انات مرحبا بك كيف تراقبون تطور
الوضع في السودان
الوضع مروع للغايه
ونرى المدنيين عالقون في اطلاق النار بين
القوات المسلحه
او قوات الدعم السريع كما تعلمون الناس
عالقون في هذا الوضع لخمسه ايام لا يمكن
لهم الوصول الى الطعام او المياه او
الدواء وايضا فرقت وشتت العائلات عن بعضها
البعض وهذا القتال ينتشر الى الخرطوم
واماكن من دارفور واماكن اخرى ولكن هناك
امل بان يكون هناك احتفاء بالعيد بوضع
لنرى فيه وقفا لاطلاق النار كي يتمكن
المدنيون لعدد من الايام ان يجدوا سبيلا
للوصول الى السلامه والامان وايضا لكل من
هم بحاجه للاجلاء ان يتم اجلائهم على ماذا
تعلقون الامل في ان يحدث مثل هكذا امر ان
يتم وقف اطلاق النار بعد ان
اخفقت الهدى في الايام السابقه
انت محقه نحن كنا نامل على مدى خمسه ايام
ان يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار بعد الكثير
من المفاوضات الان هناك الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده
والايجاد
والدول الخمس في مجلس الامن الدولي
والاتحاد الافريقي والسعوديه ومصر كلهم
معا ويرسلون رساله قويه
ويناشدون البرهان وحميتي لكي يبدا في وقف
اطلاق النار خلال فتره العيد واعتقد ان
الرد كان مريحا نوعا ما وموثوقا ولكن لا
يمكن ان نثق بما يجري لان الاربعه ايام
الماضيه تم التفاوض بشان هدنه ولم تحترم
ولم يتم هذا
انت تتحدثين عن ارسال رسائل وعن حث وطلب
ولكن ماذا عن الضغوط التي يمكن ان تمارسها
كل هذه الجهات الدوليه الفاعله من اجل وضع
حد للقتال وحمل الاطراف فعليا على وقف
اطلاق النار
الان هو ان هناك قتال حتى النهايه
ونرى هناك غضب
يطغى على الرشد والحكمه
وعدد من رؤساء الدول ذكروا الاطراف بانه
سيكون هناك تداعيات اذا واضح من كل جهودنا
كلنا بان عليهم مسؤوليه في السودان ان
يحترموا المدنيين وان يحترموا الارواح كي
لا تزهق وهذا من اجل خير المدنيين
وسلامتهم بان يكون هناك هدنه لكي يستطيع
المدنيون بالتالي ايضا ان يتحقق لهم
السلام وان يستطيعوا ان يصلوا الى الطعام
والمياه اذا فهذه دعوه من المجتمع الدولي
للطرفين بانه سوف يكون عليهما مسؤوليه اذا
مل لم يقوم بذلك ولكن في الوقت الحاضر
نناشده بوضع الهدنه اولا سيكون عليهما
مسؤوليه ما الذي سيترتب على هذه المسؤوليه
ان لم يلت
التفاوضوا من يوم الى يوم وكما قلت انفا
ما نسمعه من الخرطوم الان هو ان القتال لم
يستانف لذلك لدينا بعض الامل والان على
الطرفين ان يفهمان عليهما مسؤوليه نحن هنا
لا نتحدث عن سبل اخرى واجراء اخرى فكل
الاطراف وضحت بان هذا الامر غير مقبول ولا
يمكن للطرفين الاستمرار بهذا القتال
والهجوم على المدنيين اذا هذا هو النقاش
الذي عقدناه معا خلال الاجتماع اليوم وامل
ان يكون لديه ما يكفي من القوه لكي يستقطب
بنهايه الامر ويستدعي ردا قويا بمقابل ذلك
ما هي مخاوفكم في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
استمرت الاوضاع بالتدهور على الصعيد
العسكري واستمر القتال
هذا ما نناقشه ليل نهار كما تعلمون وعلينا
واجب ان نتعامل مع مواطنينا ولدينا
اكثر من 1500 مواطن اوروبي في السودان
وهذا اعتبروا احدى اولوياتنا لكي يكون
لديهم سبيل للمرور العابر الامن وايضا لكي
يكون هناك سبيل للمنظمات الانسانيه ان
تدخل الى السودان لكي يساعد الناس فهناك
كارثه انسانيه تتجلى فصولها وايضا نحن
كمجتمع دولي علينا مسؤوليه ايضا ان نوجه
الرساله لطرفي القتال بان عليهما ان يضعا
السلاح جانبا شكرا
انات مبعوثه الاتحاد الاوروبي للقرن
الافريقي السفيره
فالعرض التالي نستعرض كيف رسم البرهان
وحميتي خلال حديثهما مع الجزيره رؤيتيهما
للصراع الجاري
في حديث خاص مع الجزيره يرسم طرف الصراع
في السودان رؤيتهما للمشهد الحالي البدايه
مع رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان
يحمل الرجل قوات الدعم السريع مسؤوليه
تفجر المعارك
ويتهمها باستهداف الدوله السودانيه
للاستيلاء عليها البرهان وفي مقابله خاصه
مع الجزيره قال ان تحرك الدعم السريع ياتي
على خلفيه منع توحيد القوات المسلحه واتهم
الدعم السريع بمحاوله تحويل الاتفاق
الايطالي لصالح قائده واعتبر ان الدعم
السريع ومن وصفهم بالاسلاميين المتطرفين
نظراء
اما قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميدتي سيتهم البرهان بتنفيذ انقلاب في
السودان وبعدم الالتزام بالاتفاق الايطالي
ويؤكد في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره ان قواته
تقاتل دفاعا عن النفس حسب وصفه
بالنسبه له فان الهدف من هذه العمليه
العسكريه هو التخلص من البرهان وايداعه
السجن ووقف سيطره من وصفهم بالاسلاميين
على القرار في الجيش لا يقف التراشق
الكلامي عند هذا الحد يتعدى الى اتهام كل
طرف للاخر للتعاون مع قوى خارجيه يتحدث
البرهان عن معلومات تفيد بان دولا لم
يسميها تحاول التدخل في الشان السوداني
ويؤكد ايضا ان الجيش لا يسمح بوصول اي دعم
خارجي للطرف الاخر وينفي بشكل قاطع تسلم
دعم من اي دوله خارجيه
بدوره يصف حميدتي غريمه البرهان بانه مجرد
مستخدم لدى اخرين وانه يفتقد للقدره على
اتخاذ القرارات وينفي تسلم اي مساعدات
خارجيه وايضا اي علاقه بين قوته وميليشيا
فاكرر ومع تصاعد المواقف يبقى السؤال ما
هو الحل كما يراه كل طرف بالنسبه للبرهان
فان حديث السياسه مع قوات الدعم السريع لم
يعد ممكنا فاي تفاوض مع من وصفهم
بالخارجين عن القانون والمتمردين ليس
مقبولا لا يقفل البرهان باب الحوار نهائيا
لكنه يقول ان التفاوض ممكن مع من لم يتورط
في القتال من قاده الدعم السريع اما
بالنسبه لحميتي فان الحل الوحيد للازمه
يتلخص في تسليم البرهان للعداله كما يقول
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا تحتدم المواجهات في محيط المؤسسات
السياديه في الخرطوم معركه المطار تستمر
لليوم السادس دون حسم وكذلك الامر في محيط
القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش
ويمتد القتال الى مناطق اخرى المشهد
الميداني خلال ساعات الماضيه في العرض
التالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حصلت الجزيره على صور تظهر احتراق طائره
مدنيه في مطار الخرطوم الدولي مساء اليوم
وعلمت الجزيره ان الاشتباكات المسلحه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تجري
في الجزء الشمالي الغربي للمطار باتجاه
مبنى القياده العامه ولم يتسنى التاكد ان
كانت الطائره قد اشتعلت نتيجه اصابتها
بقذيفه او لسبب اخر
ويتزايد تركيز طرفي القتال في السودان على
السيطره على مطار الخرطوم الدولي وسط
تبادل كل من الجيش والدعم السريع التاكيد
انه الطرف الذي يسيطر فعليا على المطار
لم تكت شراره الاشتباكات الاولى تندلع بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
المدينه الرياضيه الجنوبيه العاصمه
الخرطوم حتى انتقل مشهد القتال السريعا
الى مطار الخرطوم الدولي لتتحول السيطره
عليه الى اولويه قصوى لطرفي الصراع يقع
المطار الذي يعد اكبر مطارات البلاد في
قلب العاصمه الخرطوم وهو المقر الرئيسي
ومركز عمليات الخطوط الجويه السودانيه
ويشكل منفذا لمرور نحو 95% من حركه
الطيران الخارجيه ويلاصق الصوره الجنوبي
لمقر القياده العامه للجيش الذي يشهد
بدوره اشتباكات متواصله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ورغم ان مطار الخرطوم يعد مطار
مدنيا فان هناك قاعده جويه كبيره ملحقه به
يربط فيها سرب من الطائرات الحربيه اضافه
الى تمركز دائم
[موسيقى]
كان هذا المشهد في الخرطوم وضواحيها اما
في مدينه الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان فقد
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان اشتباكات جرت بين
قوات الجيش والدعم السريع كما شهدت مدينه
الفاشر في ولايه شمال دارفور بدورها معارك
بين الطرفين ورجح مراسلنا ان تكون حول
معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع بالمنطقه وقالت
مصادر طبيه ان مستشفى مدينه الفاشر اقتض
بالمصابين كما اظهرت صور التهام النيران
لسوق معسكر نيفاشا بالمدينه جراء
الاشتباكات
في تداعيات الانسانيه للقتال تستمر
النداءات العاجله لتوفير ممر انساني في
السودان وسط تواصل الاقتتال بين الفرقاء
السياسيين وتداول الوضع الانساني في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى ضمن دائره
العنف الدامي
مشيا على الاقدام ولمسافات طويله احيانا
تحت القصف ووسط الجثث وبين الدبابات يغادر
السودانيون الخرطوم مدينه تحت النار
والعنف الى اجل غير مسمى الفرار لكثيرين
كان خيارا بين المر والامر اما البقاء في
مناطق لا تعرف الاشتباكات فيها هدنه منذ
السبت الدامي او الهروب وسط خشيه تعرض
المنازل للنهب والقص الوصول الى ولايه
اكثر امنا ليس خاتمه الاحزان الوطن كله
بحسابات السياسه وفوض السلاح في ازمه قد
تكون الاخطر في تاريخه الحديث التغريبه
السودانيه بدات فعلا استنادا للامم
المتحده ما بين عشره الاف وعشرين الف شخص
فروا من البلد الى الجاره تشاد في عاصمه
بنيتها التحتيه متهالكه في الايام العاديه
هي الان مسرح مفتوح على كل الازمات
الانسانيه بتفاصيلها المؤلمه جدا والمستم
مع كل هدنه تخترق في دقائقها الاولى من
سيء الى اسوا تصف التقارير المحليه
والدوليه اوضاع المستشفيات المؤسسات
الطبيه في البلد بحاجه الى من يسعفها بشكل
مرعب يرتفع اعداد المرضى والمصابين
المدنيين الذين يموتون بسبب غياب العلاج
اعلنت نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ارتفاع
عدد المستشفيات المتوقفه كليا عن الخدمه
الى 52 من اصل 74 في العاصمه الخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى التي تكتوي بنار
المواجهات المسلحه اضافت النقابه ان تسعه
من المستشفيات التي اعلنت خارج الخدمه
كانت قد تعرضت للقصر وبان 19 مستشفى اخليت
بشكل قصري مستشفيات في وسط الخرطوم مهدده
بالتوقف عن العمل نظرا الى نقص الامدادات
والكوادر الطبيه
المسلحون بهم صمم منذ السبت الماضي عن
عشرات النداءات الاستغاثه من الداخل
والخارج لتوفير ممرات انسانيه للمدنيين
وندعو جميع الاطراف الى تنفيذ توقف انساني
مستدام في اقرب وقت ممكن لكي يتمكن اولئك
المحاصرون بسبب القتال من البحث عن الملف
[تصفيق]
لسقفه ولا جدار في الخرطوم يستطيع في هذه
الايام العصيبه ان يكون عازلا لرصاص
يتطاير في السماء مثل عاصفه رمليه استنفذ
عمال الاغاثه كل المفردات لوصفه رشيديا
التي يعيشها الناس قال المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني ان المستشفيات
منهاره تماما وخاليه من كل المستلزمات
الوضع اكثر من كارثي الخرطوم الامنه حتى
في اوج الحروب التي شهدتها ولايات في
السودان خسرت هذا الوصف في صراع اسكن
الرعب في قلوب الملايين اقتتال سيحرم
السودانيين مما بقي من فرحه العيد في وطن
لم تترك الماتم والماسي فيه مكانا سوى
للحزن والخشيه من ان يطول هذا الكابوس
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم عبدو دينج المنسق
الاممي لشؤون الانسانيه في السودان مرحبا
بك سيد عبده ساستعير من مقالته الزميله
مريم اوبيش في تقريرها قبل قليل لقد
استنفذت المفردات لوصف الوضع الانساني في
السودان في ضوء ما يجري الى اين تتجه
الامور
بالقول
واقتبس من الامين العام للامم المتحده
الذي تحدث عن الوضع ووصف وبانه كارثي ما
نلاحظه هنا في الخرطوم هو امر مقلق للغايه
كل القطاعات
قد ضربت بهذه الازمه سواء كان هذا الامر
متعلقا بالطعام او المياه او قطاع الرعايه
الصحيه او حمايه الناس والسكان كل قطاع
الان بحاجه الى ان تتوفر له الخدمات وبسبب
القتال فان من هم قائمون الان على
النشاطات الانسانيه لا يمكن لهم ان يقدموا
هذه الخدمات والبلد اصلا كان في وضع معقد
للغايه حتى قبل هذه الازمه وهذا من شانه
ان يضيف الى ما هو موجود اصلا ولذلك
فبالتالي نناشد كل الاطراف لكي تقوم بوقف
القتال فورا والا
فيجب
السماح لهدنه لكي نستطيع نحن ان نقدم
خدماتنا للسودانيين
سيد عبده انتم في المنسقيه الامميه
للشؤون الانسانيه في السودان ماذا تفعلون
من اجل فرض مثلا موضوع الممر الانساني
الذي يجري الحديث عنه وامكانيه تامين الحد
الادنى رغم استمرار القتال
اليوم لا يمكن القيام باي شيء طالما ان
القتال مستمر ولهذا السبب نحن نناشد من
اجل هدنه لكي نستطيع تقديم هذه الخدمات
الانسانيه
عشر منظمات امميه دوليه موجوده هنا لتقدم
الخدمات بالاضافه الى مئات المنظمات غير
الحكوميه
250 مشروع كانت جاريه ولكن الان كل شيء
توقف والناس بحاجه للخدمات الاساسيه الناس
بحاجه الى الطعام والمياه والحمايه
والرعايه الصحيه
والقتال
الجاري لا يسمح لاي من هذه الخدمات ان يتم
تقديمها على الاطلاق طبعا قطاع المستشفيات
يعاني معاناه كبيره الكثير من المستشفيات
بدات تخرج عن الخدمه تماما في الخرطوم الى
اي حد يقلقكم هذا الموضوع
نحن كلنا
نخشى ان تندلع كارثه في السودان
منظفون رعايه الصحيه لا يمكن لهم ان
يخرجوا من بيوتهم لكي يقدموا الخدمات
والبنيه التحتيه لرعايه الصحيه يتم قصفها
الان المدارس ايضا يتم قصفها اذا كل هذا
يجب ان يتوقف والا
في الايام القادمه
سنرى ازمه انسانيه تتجلى في السودان كيف
ايضا تراقبون تفاقم ازمه اللاجئين هناك
الالاف الذين يفرون الى تشاد ماذا عن هذا
الجانب
ابدا بالحديث عن هؤلاء الناس العرضه للخطر
في السودان هناك ثلاث فاصل سبعه مليون شخص
مشردون في دارفور بشكل اساسي وهناك عدد من
اللاجئين ايضا في البلد
[موسيقى]
ناهيك عن الناس الذين خرجوا من السودان
الى تشاد وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى كل
هؤلاء يجب ان توفر لهم الحمايه واليوم
حمايه هؤلاء الناس بالاضافه الى حمايه
السودانيين هو تقريبا مستحيل اذا ما استمر
القتال شكرا جزيلا لك
المنسق الاممي لشؤون الانسانيه في السودان
عبده دينغ ضيفا من الخرطوم
في الجهود الدوليه سعيه لتهدئه الوضع شارك
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو اليوم
في اجتماع افتراضي مغلق جمعه مع رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي والامين العام لجامعه
دول العربيه والامين التنفيذي للهيئه
الحكوميه الدوليه المعنيه بالتنميه
ومنظمات اخرى ذات صله لمناقشه التطورات في
السودان وكان المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده قال امس ان الامين العام
اجرم مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس الكيني بشان
الاوضاع في السودان واكد انه سيواصل
الانخراط بشكل كامل في الموضوع واجراء
مكالمات هاتفيه اضافيه لتامين وقف اطلاق
نار لمده 24 ساعه
وقد دعا غوتييرش الاطراف المتنازعه في
السودان الى وقف اطلاق النار فورا لمده
ثلاثه ايام خلال عيد الفطر اضاف غوتييرش
ان العمليات الانسانيه صارت شبه مستحيله
بسبب تعرض المستودعات والمركبات والاصول
الانسانيه الاخرى للدمار والنهب
اولويه فوريه ادعو الى وقف اطلاق النار
لمده ثلاثه ايام على الاقل خلال عيد الفطر
ليتمكن جميع المدنيين في مناطق النزاع من
الحصول على العلاج الطبي والغذاء
والمستلزمات الاساسيه الاخرى هذه هي
الخطوه الاولى التي يجب القيام بها ومن ثم
يجب ان يكون هناك وقف دائم للقتال لقد
بذلت جهدا شخصيا لتحقيق ذلك وقف
الاعتداءات يجب ان يعقبه حوار جدي يسمح
بانتقال الناجح للسلطه يبدا بتعيين حكومه
مدنيه يجب ان يتوقف القتال فورا
قالت جون كيردي منسق للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان الولايات المتحده ستنظر في
مجموعه من الادوات والخيارات لاجبار
الطرفين المتصارعين في السودان على وقف
القتال واكد كيربي في مؤتمر صحفي ان
التركيز منصب على حث الجانبين على التوصل
الى وقف اطلاق النار
مازلنا قلقين للغايه بشان العنف واستمرار
القتال وعدم صمود وقف اطلاق النار الليله
الماضيه ما يعني استمرار تعرض المدنيين
للاذى لن استبق اي قرارات بعقوبات او ما
شابه ذلك لكننا سننظر دائما في مجموعه من
الادوات والقدرات لدينا لنحاول اجبار كلا
الجانبين على وقف هذا العنف تركيزنا حاليا
منصب على حث كلا الجانبين على وقف العنف
والتوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار للسماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى من هم بحاجه
اليها لان الوضع مريع في الخرطوم وهناك
بالفعل نقص في الغذاء والمياه والادويه
وقال كريبي ان الرئيس بايدن وجه الجيش
الامريكي لارسال وحدات عسكريه لتمركز
بالقرب من السودان لاجلاء الرعايه
الامريكيين حال الاضطرار لذلك مشيرا الى
اتصال بايدن المنتظم بفريق الامن القومي
لمعرفه ما يدور في السودان
[موسيقى]
لديه اطلاع حديث على ما يدور من احداث في
الخرطوم وهو على اتصال منتظم بفريق الامن
القومي فيما يخص الاحداث في السودان منذ
بدء العنف هناك الرئيس بايدن اذن للجيش
بالمضي قدما في التمركز المسبق قريبا من
هناك وتوفير خيارات في حال اردنا واشدد
على في حال اردنا اجراء المواطنين من هناك
الخبير في شؤوني شمال افريقيا في مركز
ستارتفر للدراسات الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك
سيد راين ما هي الادوات والخيارات التي
تفكر فيها هذه الاداره
لفرضها على طرفي القتال لحملهما على وقف
هذه المواجهات العسكريه من وجهه نظرك
يمكن ان نفكر بالامر من خلال هدفين هدف
قصير المدى وهدف بعيد المدى قصير المدى
متعلق بالحفاظ على ارواح المواطنين
الامريكان في السودان وخاصه حول السفاره
وايضا هناك العامل العسكري فهناك امكانيه
انه في الايام القادمه الولايات المتحده
تنظر في بعث عسكريه للخرطوم لاجلاء الناس
والموظفين هناك وقد يقومون بهذا من خلال
الدبلوماسيه لضمان انها تسير بشكل حسن
ولكن عمليه اجلاء الامريكان هذا امر غير
واقعي الان بالنظر للقتال في العاصمه وعلى
المدى البعيد يريدون وقف لاطلاق النار
وهذا يتطلب اقناع طرفين بالابتعاد عن
التصعيد ولكن هذه الخيارات بحد ذاته هي
محدوده
ولكن ما هي هذه الخيارات على محدووديتها
ما الذي يتم التفكير به في داخل هذه
الاداره
الاول الولايات المتحده ان تفعله هو
التواصل مع مصر والامارات والسعوديه ودول
اقليميه اخرى وحتى الاردن والذين لديهم
نفوذ دبلوماسي معتبر مع الطرفين في
السودان ايضا الاسرائيليون والذين ايضا
لديهم روابط مع طرفين منذ عمليه التطبيع
عام 2020 وذلك لبناء ثقه بين الطرفين
والاقناعيهما بتخفيض التصعيد وايضا بعدم
تغذيه هذا القتال هناك تقارير اوليه
بان خليفه حفتر من ليبيا قدم مساعدات
محدوده ومصر ايضا قدمت مساعدات محدوده
الامريكان لا يريدون ان يصبح هذا القتال
بالوكاله ولا يريدون ان يكون هناك جهود من
دول عربيه لكي يفعل كلنا بوسعه لصالحه
الخاص عدا عن ذلك هناك عقوبات وح عقوبات
لا يريدون اللجوء اليها فورا لان العقوبات
في الخرطوم قد تؤدي الى انهاء عمليه
التطبيع مع اسرائيل ولكن اذا ما استمر
القتال وخاصه لفتره طويله وان كان هناك
ضحايا باعداد كبيره بين المدنيين اذا
فربما تفكر الولايات المتحده بفرضه عقوبات
وخاصه اذا ما توافق الحلفاء والولايات
المتحده على ان العقوبات يستبيل الوحيد
لوقف هذا القتال شكرا لك الخبير في شؤون
شمال افريقيا في مركز الشاطر للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من واشنطن
تراقب دول الجوار الوضع في السودان وتبدي
تخوفها من استمرار النزاع وخروجه عن
السيطره كما لا تتخوف من تدخلات اجنبيه
تؤجج الصراع وتطيل امده هذا التقرير يعرض
بعض مواقف دول الجوار من النزاع الدائري
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
الحرب المشتعله في السودان يمكن ان يتطاير
لها الى دول الجوار تدرك هذه الدول هذه
الحقيقه وتعرف ان ما يحدث يهدد الاستقرار
في المنطقه مصر الجار الشمالي حدد وزير
خارجيه اسامح شكري موقفها في ثلاث نقاط
ضروره التواصل مع طرفي النزاع لحقن دماء
السودانيين ضروره التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار في اقرب وقت ممكن ضروره التعامل مع
النزاع القائم كشان داخلي تشير النقطه
الاخيره الى مخاوف من تدخلات اجنبيه تطيل
النزاع وتعقد الحل مع ما يتبع ذلك من
تاثير في الامن الاقليمي هذه المخاوف عبرت
عنها الجاره الجنوبيه اثيوبيا التي شهدت
علاقاتها مع السودان توترا ملحوظا في
الاونه الاخيره بسبب نزاعات حدوديه حذر
رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا ابي احمد من اي
محاولات ذات دوافع واجندات خفيه للتدخل في
الشان السوداني تسعى لتدمير مقدرات البلاد
حسب تعبيره دوله جنوب السودان التي كان
اهلها يشاركون السودانيين الب واحد قبل
الانقسام تعيش مشكلات داخليه كثيره ويعرف
ساستها ان هذه المشكلات ستتعقد اكثر اذا
استمر النزاع في السودان رئيسها عرض وساطه
في اطار منظمه ايجاد واعلن مع رؤساء دول
اخرى بالمنطقه زياره قريبه للخرطوم لكن
الحرب الدائره هناك حاله دون ذلك في تشاد
التي يبلغ طول حدودها مع السودان اكثر من
1400 كيلومتر قالت الحكومه انها اغلقت
حدودها مع السودان وناشدت المجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي وكذلك جميع الدول
الصديقه منحى الاولويه لعوده السلام كما
اعلن وزير دفاعها عن استقبال مئات الجنود
السودانيين الذين دخلوا اراضيها اما ليبيا
التي دفعت ايضا ثمن تطاحن بين ابناء البلد
الواحد فوضعها الداخلي بدا واضحا في رد
فعلها وزيره الخارجيه في الحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه نجلاء المنقوش عبرت عن استعداد
بلادها لاداء دور الوساطه ودعت الى
الاستجابه للنداءات التي تطالب بوقف
الاشتباكات فورا وتغليف لغه الحوار بين
الاشقاء تدعو المنقوش لتغذيب لغه الحوار
وتنقل صحيفه الامريكيه عن مصادر ان اللواء
الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ارسل طائره
واحده على الاقل لنقل امدادات عسكريه
لقوات الدعم السريع في السودان لا يمكن
فصل موقف دول الجوار عن موقف اطراف دوليه
اخرى تسعى لاستغلال الصراع في السودان لكن
دول الجوار هي التي ستدفع الثمن بعد
السودانيين اذا تعقد النزاع والصعصى على
الحل
في موضوع اخر اصدر قاضي التحقيق بالمحكمه
الابتدائيه في تونس العاصمه قرارا بسجن
رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي على خلفيه
تصريحات راى فيها النائب العام مسا بامن
الدوله واثر قرار سجن الغنوش ردود فعل
داخليه وخارجيه اعتبرته استهدافا لمعارضي
الرئيس قيس سعيد وانتهاكا للحريات
الاساسيه
من هنا بدات الحكايه ندوه لجبهه الخلاص
الوطني قال خلالها راشد الغنوشي انه لا
يمكن تصور تونس دون حركه النهضه ودون
احزاب اليسار لان ذلك قد يقود البلاد الى
حرب اهليه حسب تعبيره تم اعاقه في تونس
هي الحقيقه للحرب الاهليه النائب العام
راى في تصريحات الغنوشي ما يمس امن الدوله
فامر باعتقاله
هيئه الدفاع عن الغنوشي رفضت الاتهامات
جمله وتفصيلا وطعنت في الملف معتبره ان
الاجراءات القانونيه باطله وان وسائل
الاثبات متلاعب فيها
طلبنا من منوبنا عدم امضاء المحاضر هديه
لانه فيها
قامت على هاني قلت لك على مؤيد تمت عمليه
فبركته تجزئه هذا
الخطاب والاسئله التي وجهت للمنوع وعمليه
الاستنطاق لم تعرض عليهم مؤيدات القوه
المعارضه للسلطه تستهزنت قرار اعتقال
الغنوشي وقالت ان دوافعه سياسيه خالصه
واعتبرت جبهه الخلاص الوطني ان سجن
الغنوشي يدل على انهيار حاله الحريات في
البلاد السلطات تعتبر ان الامر يتعلق
بمجرد ادعاءات مثل ما جاء في ردها على عدد
من الدول والهيئات الدوليه التي عبرت عن
انزعاجها من اعتقال الغنوشي فوزاره
الخارجيه شددت على ان قوانين الجمهوريه
ساريه على جميع المتقاضين على حد سوا ودون
تمييز مع توفير كافه الضمانات اللازمه وان
العداله تمارس برصانه دون تاثر بموجه
التعليقات غير المقبوله على حد وصفها
وياتي اعتقال راس الغنوشي في سياق سياسي
اتسم بموجه من الاعتقالات طالت قيادات
اخرى من حركه النهضه بتهم مختلفه بالاضافه
الى عدد من السياسيين من احزاب اخرى فيما
تصنفه سلطات التونسيه تامرا على امن
الدوله وتعتبره المعارضه استهدافا سياسيا
عبر القضاء لاخلاء الساحه من اي صوت معارض
على طرفي نقي تقف السلطه والمعارضه في
تونس بل هو بين مواقفهما تتسع يوما بعد
اخر واقع جعل البلاد تنزلق نحو مرحله
جديده تزيد الافق السياسيا سدادا لطف حجم
الجزيره تونس
مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون معكم في هذه
التغطيه لكافه الشؤون في السودان نتابع
معكم اخر التطورات الميدانيه والسياسيه
وايضا المشهد الدولي فيما يخص الضغوط